النقطات الايرانيه بعد ان تمكنت خلال
الايام الثلاثه الماضيه من السيطره بطريقه
او باخرى على الشارع الايراني ومنعت الى
درجه كبيره تشكل مظاهرات كبيره في عدد
كبير من المدن والمحافظات الايرانيه ومن
بينها العاصمه الايرانيه طهران تتجه
الانظار بشده او انضاف الى خمسه مدن كرديه
ايرانيه
هذه المدن تشهدوا
مواجهات ساخنه وداميه بين القوى الامنيه
المتظاهرين منذ ثلاثه ايام وقبل ثلاثه
ايام انتشرت صور عبر مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي تثبيت الدخول في رقم من القوى
الامنيه مجاهدكم باسلحه من العيار الثقيل
لم يشهدها في المدن الاخرى التي شهدت
الانتشارا امنيا
بدولها القوى الامنيه في هذه التجهيزات او
المعدات الحربيه الى تلك الموضوع وتم
الاعلان على انها حمله بح في اعتقاله
مواصفات
المحردين على الفوضى وزعتعه الامن
والاستقرار في تلك المدينه والتابعين
لاحزاب الكرديه الانفصاليه على الانفصاليه
التي تصفها طهران بالارهابيات بطبعه الحال
الاجواء امنيه مشدده تشهدها هذه المدن
الكرديه الصوره التي تصل من هناك تتحدث عن
مواجهات عنيفه وتمويه
مهابات همم البرلمان الايراني الذي تحدثت
وكشف على ان عدد حلقاتنا في مدينه او
الضحايا هذه المواجهات الثانيه بين الدول
الامنيه المتظاهرين في خلال موجه احتجاجات
الاخيره او في الشهرين الماضيين همم وصل
الى 11 ثم طبعا هذه الارقام التي كشف عنها
النائب في البرلمان الايراني همم تتصل على
عدد الضحايا قبل الايام الثلاثه الماضيه
همم فيما تتحدث منظمات حقوقيه ومنظمه حقوق
البشر الايرانيه طبعا هي جهاز غير رسميا
احنا لا يمكن ان نؤكد او ننفي اخبار هل
لكنها تتحدث عن وقوع 14 قتيلا في مدينه
مهابات واحده خلال ايام ثلاثه الماضيه ما
يعني اننا ربما نواجهونك ازمه او
المواجهات الانبياء الاكثر عمرامه الاخيره
طبعا هذه الموجات لا تقصر على مدينه
مادبات هناك صور كثيره وصلت وصلت
اوضاعا كارثيه همم كارثيه في مدينه
بوكا من